San Francisco looks and feels like a big
city but it's actually quite small it
has a population of under a million and
is only 47 square miles but what it
lacks in size it makes up for in price
San Francisco is amongst America's most
expensive cities
the soaring cost of living and the
injection of Silicon Valley money has
led some people to claim that challenge
lost its soul but have no fear there's
still plenty of mojo left by the bay
welcome to San Francisco
[Music]
San Francisco is the cultural commercial
and financial center of Northern
California the city's reputation is
built on its colorful history it hosted
The Beat Generation and the free love
movement of the 60s and 70s and was the
birthplace of pride these days the
bohemian dream is up against it the
average rent for a one-bedroom apartment
is over three thousand dollars nearly
four times the u.s. national average so
when checking out the city start by
dodging the traffic and embracing your
inner flower power by grabbing a bike
although San Francisco's famed for its
steep hills many parts of the city are
actually relatively flat start your
journey at Pier 39 and pay a visit to
the seals these guys turned up after the
earthquake of 1989 and have stayed ever
since
[Music]
a 10-minute ride away is Chinatown this
is the oldest and second largest
Chinatown in North America and despite
all the city's rapid changes it remains
unbowed
House of Nanking is famous for its
delicious cuisine and direct service
that some people might find a bit rude
but don't take it personally it's all
part of the experience
[Music]
another quick ride will get you from
Chinatown to South of Market or soma
this vast warehouse filled district is
home to countless live workspaces
red door coffee inside the 111 Mina Art
Gallery is the perfect place to chill
for a moment before heading into the
heart of the mission the decades the
mission was a middle-class immigrant
Enclave but it was steadily gentrified
by hipsters starting in the 90s here
you'll find some of the world's best
burritos served up mission-style de
Korea
El Castillo is one of the best don't let
their lack of de coeur ward you off this
is the real deal
now you're fueled up it's time to tackle
the hills riding up to the Golden Gate
Park is worth the effort
[Music]
you'll pass Buffalo's windmills the
Academy of Arts and Science and the
flower conservatory all on your way to
the Pacific now kick your feet up in
luxury at sutras cliff house stylish
restaurant and lounge with stunning
panoramic views perfect place to unwind
and watch the sunset
[Music]
you
you